ان جلى غبار كارثه زلزال كهرمان مرش لكن
تداعياتها زادت المشهد السياسيه في تركيا
تعقيدا فالسباق الانتخابي اصطدم بالكارثه
التي ضربت جنوبي البلاد في السادس من شباط
الماضي اي قبل نحو 100 يوم من موعد
الاقتراع وتحولت الولايات المنكوبه الى
ساحه للمنافسه الانتخابيه فالاطراف
المتنافسه تدرك الحجم الانتخابي الكبيره
للولايات المتضرره من الزلزال وتاثير
اصوات ناخبين في العمليه الانتخابيه
ولاهميه هذه الاصوات اكدت اللجنه العليا
للانتخابات اتخاذها تدابير تسهل مشاركه
المتضررين من الزلزال
كانشاء صناديق اختراع في مراكز الايواء
والسماحل الناخبين النازحين بتغيير
عناوينهم المسجله
من الزلزال اتخذنا الاجراءات اللازمه
بخصوص الانتخابات جهزنا مراكز للاقتراع في
مراكز الايواء لتمكين المواطنين من
الادلاء باصواتهم الانتخابيه حتى الرابع
عشر من مايو يوم الانتخابات ستكون كل
التحضيرات جاهزه
ملف الزلزال غدا احد اهم عناوين الحملات
الانتخابيه
كانت من خلاله المعارضه اتهاماتها للحكومه
بالتقصير في اتخاذ تدابير احترازيه تحد من
الخسائر ناهيك عن اتهامات اخرى ببطء
الاستجابه مقابل ذلك شرعت الحكومه في
اجراءات تخفف معانات الناجين من خلال
توفير بدائل مؤقته لايوائهم والتعهد
باعاده الاعمار خلال عام واحد تراهن
الحكومه على تجاربها السابقه في اعاده
الاعمار خصوصا زلزل عام 2020 لكن هل
تبقيها نتائج الانتخابات في سده الحكم
لاكمال ما بداته
فالايام الاولى من الزلزال شاهدنا بعض
التقصير تجاه المتضررين بعد ذلك تداركت
الحكومه الامر واتخذت خطوات كبيره للتعاطي
مع الكارثه وحضي ذلك بتقدير الناس براي
حتما سيكون هناك تاثير للزلزال على
الانتخابات ليس على مستوى القاعده
الجماهيريه والمستوى المامول من قبل
المعارضه انما على صعيد فردي
تعتبر مناطق الزلزال مع عاقل انتخابيه
للعداله والتنميه والزلزال شكل فرصه
للمعارضه لمحاوله اختراقها خصوصا ان الافا
ينتظرون في مراكز الايواء حتى الان رغم
انطلاق عمليه تسليم المنازل للمتضررين
الزلزال ظاهره طبيعيه لا تحاسب الحكومات
على وقوعها لكنها تسال عما اذا اتخذ
التدابير تحد من خسائرها فهل قدرتها على
لملمه اثار الكارثه تعكس الجدل لمصلحتها
سجال سياسي يفرضه زلزال كهرمان مرش في
الانتخابات تركيا عمر حلبي الجزيره نورداغ
غازي عنتاب جنوبي تركيا